hey quick update you may have noticed
that you're not getting our videos in
your feed a few people of complain
that's because YouTube is changing their
system now or they're putting
subscriptions kind of on the back burner
and pushing forward their recommended
feed so you need to subscribe and hit
the bell right next to subscribe
allowing for notifications if you want
to see our stuff and unfortunately this
is not great for our content creators
and really conserve to only increase
clickbait which is a growing problem on
YouTube Steven I'm uploading the new
video shameful display have you to bury
dr. clickbait yes what are you doing
yeah that's all wrong this kind of
content will never make anyone's
recommended feed our subscribers they
love this kind of content anymore my
recommendation see that they are now
lead you know what that's on their
request it young-ran it's either the
serve and everything mayor with tops is
a hundred and forty percent more
clickable I'd watch it with that title
it's entirely wrong it's accurate
borderline descriptive even you only do
is where the create an adversarial
nature bombastic words like fail epic
wrecked or destroyed and never forget to
mine the confirmation bias people want
you to tell them what it is they want to
hear and what will you tell them exactly
what to hear that's played in Rick's on
YouTube you need to suppose of a picture
what about image accuracy you need to
click protect - whatever habitude
honesty Oh
everything about this is awful I guess
it's not so easy to see you know where
are just following six it can be as easy
as one
but dr. clickbait we do I even start
her time sir bird you've asked you can
find it like here oh I'm get it like
yeah and so everywhere now you try okay
look here no no like whoa I think I got
it now
thanks dr. clickbait you're asking you
to subscribe to steven crowder the fine
upstanding man's Young tittle or perhaps
if not you'd prefer Ana Kasparian
yes red dresses quick paid in the word
[ __ ] how original
and I can see through